Le Café
de l'espace des sciences, avec la revue
Science Ouest,
publie alors.
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous.
Merci d'être là parmi nous.
Bienvenue au premier café de l'Espace
des sciences 2022.
C'est un grand plaisir de vous recevoir
ce soir.
Nous avons un enregistrement en cours
donc n'hésitez vraiment pas à lever,
à nous faire signe, à lever la main.
Si vous voulez participer à l'échange,
vous pouvez poser des questions
tout au long de l'événement.
Donc faites nous juste signe
pour que mon collègue puisse
vous passer un micro,
qu'on puisse bien vous entendre.
Et puis on répondra à vos questions.
Voilà donc ce soir, j'ai le plaisir d'être
accompagné de mon collègue Bruno Mauguin,
responsable du planétarium
à l'Espace des sciences.
Et donc, ce soir,
on va voyager dans l'espace.
Bruno, c'est ça.
On va tâcher de le faire, en tout cas
avec les mots et en turbulences.
Voilà,
voilà.
Donc l'idée est de revenir sur un sujet
qu'on a abordé
dans un de nos magazines.
Si on souhaite,
parce que je n'ai pas précisé.
Le Café de l'espace des sciences
est organisé
par l'équipe de la rédaction de Science.
Ou est ce que c'est
un magazine publié par l'Espace
des sciences qui paraît chaque mois ?
Et donc, pour celles
et ceux qui ne le connaîtraient pas ?
En fait,
on a toujours un dossier thématique.
Et donc, il y a quelques mois,
on a parlé du milieu Intercités.
Donc voilà,
on vient ce soir aborder certains points
qu'on a évoqué déjà dans le dossier.
Et on va peut être aller un peu plus loin
dans d'autres galaxies
pour en parler tous ensemble.
Donc pour commencer, Bruno,
j'ai une question un peu basique
mais qui, je pense, posera les bases
Qu'est ce que c'est
que le milieu interstellaire ?
Alors la question est bonne
et on va tâcher
de trouver la bonne réponse
en astronomie,
on parle du milieu interstellaire.
C'est tout l'espace qui sépare les étoiles
les unes des autres.
Il y a le milieu interplanétaire.
Pour le cas du système solaire,
il y a des planètes, il y en a huit
principales et c'est dans un environnement
qui se situe en gros autour
de 8 milliards de kilomètres de distance
par rapport au soleil.
Alors, il y a peut être des choses
qu'on appelle
le nuage de fortes réserves de comètes,
en quelque sorte.
Des blocs de glace qui devraient faire
au maximum 30 kilomètres de diamètre
et qui sont situées jusqu'à
apparemment une année lumière
du soleil.
Alors, comment on peut savoir ça ?
Parce que,
en analysant les trajectoires des comètes,
on arrive à en déduire
que pour qu'elles aient
ce type de trajectoire,
elles viennent de telle distance.
Et on connaît les trajectoires de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de comètes.
C'est comme ça qu'on arrive à avoir
une idée de ce qu'il y a à peu près
jusqu'à une année lumière du soleil.
Et puis ensuite,
et bien là, il n'y a plus rien.
C'est à dire qu'on ne voit rien.
Ce qui veut dire qu'on a le vide.
Et à partir de là, on rentre
dans le milieu dit interstellaire.
Il y a vraiment, vraiment rien.
Alors
quand on dit qu'il n'y a rien,
on ne sait pas.
Ce n'est pas tout à fait juste.
Il y a des milliards et des milliards
de particules, donc on ne les voit pas,
mais qui sont éjectées
pour la plupart par les étoiles.
Ce sont des protons en grande quantité et
il y a aussi du rayonnement.
Il y a plusieurs choses et tout cela
voyage dans l'univers.
Et pour vous donner une idée, par exemple,
vous voyez
à peu près la surface de l'ongle
d'un pouce
chaque seconde, nous avons
plusieurs milliards de particules
qui le traversent, qui nous traversent.
Donc on est constamment baigné
dans quelque chose qui n'est pas vraiment
le vide.
Alors quand on dit des milliards,
ça fait beaucoup.
Mais il faut compter
par rapport à un volume
et par rapport à un
volume, ça représente quasiment plus rien.
C'est quasiment du vide.
Donc ça veut dire que par rapport à l'air
que nous,
on respire ici, sur terre,
on ne le voit pas, on est dedans.
Mais il n'empêche que la densité de l'air
est telle que c'est bien
supérieur
à ce que l'on va rencontrer comme matière.
Quand on a quitté le système solaire
et donc dans le milieu interstellaire.
Donc il y a des grains de poussière,
c'est ça ?
Et du gaz alors ?
Y'a principalement du gaz et puis
des grains de poussière, mais.
Mais ça ne se situe pas comme cela,
de manière dispersée n'importe comment.
On a découvert que c'est organisé.
Il s'est organisé selon les lois de
la physique et entre trouve de la gravité.
C'est à dire que là, il y a des strates
et des densités de matière,
de poussière, de gaz
à certains endroits dans notre galaxie
qui font que nous avons des turbulences.
Et donc généralement,
ça se traduit par des générations
de nouvelles étoiles
et aussi des morts d'étoiles.
Donc, en fin de compte, c'est
un monde où on se dit il y a du vide.
Mais dans ce vide, il y a des zones,
des grumeaux de matière.
Et dans ces grumeaux,
il y a de l'activité.
Et cette activité,
elle se fait non pas à l'échelle humaine.
Nous, notre espérance de vie
est extrêmement courte.
C'est,
on va dire,
juste une photo sur la pellicule
d'un film,
tandis qu'une étoile va vivre des
millions, voire des milliards d'années.
Et donc, entre les étoiles qui naissent,
qui vivent, qui meurent,
il se passe plein de choses.
Il faudrait accélérer
considérablement le temps pour voir
que tout ça, ça grouille.
Nous, à notre échelle,
on a l'impression que tout est statique,
tout est figé, il ne se passe rien.
Donc ce qui amène les turbulences,
finalement,
ce sont c'est cette dynamique
des étoiles qui meurent qui naissent.
C'est toute la vie des étoiles,
finalement, qui ?
Qui est réfugiée dans ce milieu ?
Alors, effectivement,
et pour que peut être on comprenne
un petit peu les choses, parce que je vois
que souvent les gens confondent
le système solaire,
la galaxie, le big bang.
Eh bien,
on vous a amené une maquette
du système solaire.
La maquette, elle est ici.
C'est une pièce d'un centime d'euro.
0,01€ d'euro,
ça fait à peu près seize mm de diamètre.
Eh bien,
si on part du principe que
1 milliard de kilomètres,
ça fait un millimètre,
on peut réunir tout le système solaire
à l'intérieur d'une pièce d'un centime
d'euro.
0,01€ d'euro, ça veut dire que la Terre
est quasiment au centre
puisqu'on est à 150 millions de kilomètres
du Soleil.
150 millions, ça fait
à peu près 1/10 de millimètre,
un petit peu plus d'un 10ᵉ de millimètre.
Donc l'épaisseur d'une feuille de papier.
Donc nous, on est au centre.
En gros, on n'est pas grand chose,
on n'est pas grand chose là dedans.
Il y a les huit planètes principales,
donc on a le soleil au milieu
qui est une étoile.
Ensuite,
on a Mercure, Vénus, la Terre, Mars,
puis les planètes géantes
avec Jupiter, Saturne, Uranus et Neptune
et sur le bord de la
de la pièce d'un centime d'euro,
on a, à la limite
de, ce qu'on appelle la ceinture de Kuiper
super, c'est à dire
toute une réserve de cailloux si on veut.
Ça ressemble aux astéroïdes.
Sauf qu'en astronomie,
on fait la différence entre astéroïde
qui est une réserve de cailloux
qui tourne autour du Soleil
entre les trajectoires de Mars
et de Jupiter
et les objets de Kuiper.
Ça ressemble aux astéroïdes.
La chimie est un petit peu différente,
mais ils sont en train de tourner
sous forme de ceinture,
en quelque sorte autour du soleil,
à la limite de notre pièce
d'un centime d'euro.
Donc maintenant, si on dit
que le système solaire, c'est ça.
0,01€ d'euro
à 43 mètres, vous avez l'étoile
la plus proche
qui s'appelle Alpha du Centaure.
43 mètres.
Aujourd'hui, pour atteindre 43 mètres,
il faut en gros 25 000 années
avec les moyens
dont on dispose aujourd'hui pour y aller.
Pour y parvenir.
43 mètres, c'est l'étoile la plus proche
et avec nos yeux, depuis
notre petite pièce de 0,01€ d'euro,
les étoiles les plus éloignées
qu'on arrive à voir avec nos yeux
sont situées à 30 kilomètres.
Donc 30 kilomètres.
Autour de cette pièce,
on voit des étoiles.
Ça veut donc dire qu'on ne voit quasiment
rien de l'univers.
Si, toujours à cette échelle là,
la galaxie dans laquelle nous sommes,
qu'on appelle la Voie lactée,
fait 1000 kilomètres de diamètre,
c'est à dire la taille de la France.
Donc quand vous perdez une pièce
d'un centime d'euro,
vous perdez le système solaire.
Dans notre galaxie, vous voyez.
Et la galaxie la plus proche
qui ressemble à la nôtre, qu'on appelle
Andromède, galaxie d'Andromède et même 31
sept.
Cette galaxie, ça pourrait
à peu près autour de l'Australie.
Donc ça veut dire qu'entre l'Australie
et la France,
il n'y a pas d'autres galaxies.
Toutes les autres,
il y en a 200000000000, voire
même plus, sont encore beaucoup plus loin.
Voilà.
Donc je voulais donner les échelles
avec une pièce de
0,01€ d'euro
qu'on utilise tous ou de temps en temps.
Mais ça permet de resituer les choses,
c'est à dire que le système solaire
est tout petit dans notre propre galaxie.
Mais n'empêche que quand on sait que
l'étoile la plus proche est à 43 mètres
et qu'il faut 25 000 ans pour y aller
avec les moyens d'aujourd'hui,
on commence à découvrir que notre galaxie,
c'est gigantesque par rapport à nous.
Et alors ?
Petite question comment on sait tout ça ?
C'est bien parce qu'il faut quand même
qu'on parle de recherches scientifiques,
même si tout ça reste de la science,
bien sûr.
Mais est ce que je pense
notamment aux fameuses sondes Voyager
dont on nous parlait ?
Mais j'imagine que ça se compte
peut être pas en milliers d'années, mais
je pense qu'il
y a des années, des années d'études
derrière pour pouvoir
estimer ces fameuses distances.
Mais comment ? Comment ?
Aujourd'hui, on est en mesure
de connaître tous tout ceci ?
Alors on a plusieurs possibilités,
mais on va passer,
je dirais à la dernière avec Gaïa
qui est une sonde
qui a été envoyée dans l'espace
et qui a eu pour mission
d'arpenter l'univers.
Avant, il y a eu Hipparcos
qui était un satellite européen
qui a bien travaillé,
qui a mesuré à peu près
1 million d'étoiles.
La distance d'un million d'étoiles.
Alors, comment on fait pour mesurer que
la Terre tourne autour du Soleil ?
Et parce qu'elle tourne autour du soleil ?
Eh bien, c'est un peu comme nous
avec notre nez.
On va dire le nez, c'est le soleil.
Et puis quand on est en hiver, on voit
le monde avec, pourquoi pas l'œil droit.
Et comme la terre tourne six mois
plus tard, c'est plutôt l'œil gauche.
Donc on voit l'univers,
si vous voulez, en six mois,
avec sous un certain angle,
puis sous un autre.
Et cette différence angulaire,
vous vous pouvez le vérifier,
vous pointez du doigt un objet en fermant
un œil, vous ne bougez pas votre doigt.
Quand vous ouvrez l'autre œil, vous avez
l'impression que votre doit bougé.
On appelle cela la parallaxe
et cette parallaxe.
Elle est très petite à l'échelle
de notre petite pièce de
un centimes d'euro par rapport à l'univers
qu'il y a autour.
Mais on arrive à faire
des mesures angulaires de parallaxe
des étoiles les plus proches
par rapport à nous
et après c'est de la trigonométrie
tout simplement,
et ça nous permet d'arpenter l'univers
et de le voir en trois dimensions.
Et on arrive aujourd'hui
à mesurer
un peu plus du tiers de notre galaxie
de cette manière
et c'est comme ça que on reporte ensuite.
Et on a une idée de l'endroit
où se trouve exactement
comme si on était dans un arbre.
On est une feuille,
c'est le système solaire
et puis on voit d'autres feuilles
autour de nous.
On arrive à estimer les distances
et une fois
qu'on a une bonne partie de notre arbre,
on a une idée de la forme de notre arbre.
Et ensuite, à travers les branches,
on voit au loin d'autres arbres.
Il y en a
qui vont avoir la même forme que nous.
On va se dire nous, on est dans un chêne.
Là bas, on voit un autre chêne
et puis on voit un autre arbre
qui n'est pas tout à fait
comme le nôtre, qui est plutôt un sapin.
Et on va pouvoir se dire
Nous, on n'est pas dans
un sapin,
mais il y a des sapins qui existent.
Et voilà comment, de fil en aiguille,
on arrive à mesurer et à observer
l'univers.
Et au niveau de l'analyse
de la composition chimique,
parler des gaz tout à l'heure, c'est
d'autres sondes qui qui font ce job là.
Alors ça, on peut le faire directement
depuis la Terre.
Parce que l'homme,
quand il se pose des questions aussi,
il cherche des réponses
et parfois il a des
il met au point des instruments
et entre autres, avec les spectroscopie,
on va pouvoir analyser la lumière.
Vous avez tous déjà vu un arc en ciel
et ça nous paraît normal.
Quand il pleut, on voit un arc en ciel,
quand il y a le soleil qui l'éclaire. Bon,
eh bien, cette
décomposition de la lumière,
on appelle ça un spectre
et c'est toujours de la même.
Je dirais la même suite de couleurs
que l'on trouve maintenant ce spectre.
Nous, nous dieux,
nous ne nous permettent pas
de voir qu'à l'intérieur
il y a des petites choses.
Nous, on voit les couleurs, mais avec des
appareils, donc des spectroscopique.
On arrive à découvrir qu'à l'intérieur
de ces couleurs de l'arc en ciel,
il y a des traits,
il y a des réseaux à l'intérieur
et certains sont générés par la chimie
de l'étoile ou du gaz
qui va émettre de la lumière
ou en tout cas
ou qui va réfléchir de la lumière.
Il faut que ce soit
quelque chose de lumineux.
En tout cas.
Et à partir de là,
nous arc en ciel,
qu'on appelle donc des spectres.
On tous,
quand on les analyse parfaitement des
et il n'y a pas
deux étoiles
à avoir exactement le même spectre.
On retrouve des lignes générales,
mais ensuite il y a des détails
et c'est exactement comme si on analysait.
On va dire l'ADN d'un individu,
On est capable de faire la différence
entre
un scarabée, une mouche et un être humain.
Ce n'est pas le même ADN, mais ensuite,
entre eux, le singe, l'homme,
on peut constater
Et pourquoi pas le cochon et la souris ?
Il y a des points communs,
mais quand on rentre dans le détail,
il y a des différences
et c'est les différences
qui font toute la différence.
Eh bien,
on fait la même chose avec les étoiles,
on analyse les spectres et nous sur terre,
avec des lampes par exemple,
où il n'y a que de l'hélium dedans.
On le chauffe et on va découvrir des raies
et on va pouvoir superposer
les raies de l'hélium de notre loupe
par rapport aux oreilles
que l'on voit du spectre,
et on va découvrir qu'il
y a des écarts similaires
et à partir de là,
on va pouvoir identifier toutes les raies
et on fait la même chose avec du mercure,
avec tout, tout,
tous les éléments chimiques.
Et on arrive
comme cela à connaître la chimie qu'il
y a aussi bien dans les étoiles
que les nuages interstellaires.
Est ce que quelqu'un aurait une question ?
N'hésitez vraiment pas. Non,
tu es trop passionnant.
Bruno a. Moi, j'avais une petite question.
On m'a parlé de composition.
J'aimerais bien savoir,
je ne sais pas vous. Six À vous
si vous vous êtes posé la question,
mais est ce qu'il fait froid ?
Est ce qu'il y fait chaud ? Comment ça ?
Ou est ce qu'un
peu des deux je pense, c'est un milieu,
alors je juste.
Je connais un petit peu la réponse,
mais la température
que l'on va mesurer n'est pas
n'a rien à voir avec la température
que nous on mesure ici,
nous sur terre, on s'en rend pas compte,
mais on est dans un milieu,
un environnement qui est hors norme.
Nous, on a de l'air,
on a des molécules dans l'air
et donc quand on prend une température,
une température, c'est
une agitation moléculaire
Et selon la vitesse à laquelle ça va
s'agiter,
on va avoir une température
plus ou moins forte.
Donc quand on dit qu'on mesure 37
degrés, il fait 35 degrés.
Mais on a 37 degrés par rapport
à la densité de l'atmosphère
dans laquelle on se trouve.
Maintenant,
quand on va dans l'espace, dans l'espace,
il fait à peu près moins de 170 degrés,
donc il fait très froid, très très froid,
à moins de 170 degrés.
C'est la température de l'univers
là dedans,
Il y a des particules qui bougent
et on s'est rendu compte d'une chose
par exemple, au niveau du soleil,
la surface du soleil
est en gros à 6000 degrés.
Mais dès qu'on s'éloigne un peu du soleil,
on a des températures
du million de degrés.
Et pourtant, si nous,
on allait mettre la main,
il faisait très froid.
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien parce que la température, c'est
une agitation moléculaire.
Mais quand on est dans un vide,
avec des particules qui vont très vite,
le thermomètre va mesurer
les collisions de particules
et on déduire que pour qu'il
y ait cette vitesse de collision,
il faut une température.
Admettons d'un million de degrés,
ce qui est exact.
Il fait 1 million de degrés.
Mais nous, avec la densité de la matière
que nous avons, nous le sang.
Maintenant, on va être congelé.
Par contre, on vient de traverser
de pleines particules.
Alors dans l'espace, il fait très froid.
Et si jamais on y va en maillot de bain,
on ne va pas durer longtemps.
On va être congelé très très vite.
C'est pour ça que les astronautes
ont des combinaisons qui sont pressurisés,
qui sont chauffés de manière
à pouvoir compenser
les problèmes liés au soleil.
Mais on va tenter des sorties sur des gens
et entre autres, quand un astronaute
regarde le soleil,
il fait à peu près 150 degrés sur lui
alors que dans son dos,
il fait -150 degrés.
Donc, il y a 300 degrés d'écart entre eux.
Ce qu'il voit
et puis ce qu'il y a dans le dos.
Maintenant,
quand on s'éloigne encore plus,
on reçoit de moins en moins de photons,
de moins en moins de particules.
Donc la température baisse
et on est congelé.
Et du coup, quand on est dans la galaxie
qui a l'allure d'une crêpe.
Donc imaginez la France comme une crêpe.
Eh bien quand on est dans le
dans la crêpe,
on peut trouver des nuage
de gaz et de poussières qui se mélangent.
Et il y a des températures qui,
généralement sont autour de 3000 degrés.
Voilà pour les nuages de gaz.
C'est 3000 degrés.
Pour nous, c'est très chaud,
mais là encore,
c'est une particule
tous les tous les kilomètres.
Enfin et encore j'exagère
le tous les mètres,
mais en tout cas,
si nous on y allait, on serait congelé.
Mais quand on mesure
la globalité du nuage, il fait en gros
3000 degrés et 3000 degrés.
C'est
la moyenne des températures
d'un nuage de gaz
qui erre dans la galaxie,
un peu à l'image des nuages
qui parfois errent au dessus de nos têtes.
A Rennes,
on a comme cela plusieurs nuages
dans notre propre galaxie
et on a constaté que plus une galaxie
a des nuages de gaz qu'on appelle
nébuleuse interstellaires,
plus elle a la possibilité
de fabriquer des étoiles.
Et c'est là, dans ces nuages,
quand ils ce condense
qu'on a fabrication d'étoiles
et donc élévation de température où là,
on atteint des millions de degrés
et à partir de là,
on a la précipitation
ou transformation de la matière
sous forme de nuages en grappes d'étoiles.
Donc, dans le milieu interstellaire,
il y a des nuages, il y a les poussières
et quand il y a une étoile qui apparaît,
mais elle n'apparaît jamais toute seule,
elle apparaît en grappe.
A ce moment là, la masse
de cette grappe
d'étoiles va être suffisante
pour attirer la matière,
les grains de matière qui, eux,
vont peut être former des planètes.
Et après ça se stabilise,
On revient sur le 3000 degrés.
Voilà.
Alors une dynamique, finalement ?
Oui, et aujourd'hui
encore, on ne sait toujours pas
à quel moment
le nuage va fabriquer des étoiles.
On voit les nuages, on voit les étoiles.
Ça, ç'a l'air d'être un moment rapide,
mais on ne sait pas.
On ne sait pas qu'est ce qu'il déclenche.
Alors on a deux idées.
Soit le nuage se promène parmi les étoiles
et il y a un moment, il y a une étoile
un peu plus chaude que les autres.
Une étoile jeune,
généralement bien brillante,
qui va avoir une température de surface
d'à peu près 25 000 degrés.
Je dis
degrés, je dis pas en degrés qu'elle vaut
puisqu'on
y a à peu près 270 degrés d'écart.
Mais avec la température.
Donc quand on dit il y a
25000 degrés, on est à 25 000 degrés.
Mais vous comprenez que le nuage
qui lui, est à 3000 degrés,
quand il va passer avec l'étoile,
il va faire emmitouflé en quelque sorte.
Cette étoile est tellement chaude.
Ca va générer
à l'intérieur de la turbulence
parce qu'elle va générer de la turbulence.
Elle va agiter la matière interne du nuage
et c'est comme cela que vont commencer
à se former les grumeaux.
Donc on pense que pour qu'il y ait
formation d'étoiles,
il faut un gros nuage qui soit
perturbé par une étoile.
Et à ce moment là, ça s'enchaîne.
Et une fois que ça s'enchaîne,
c'est parti.
On a pour des millions,
voire des milliards d'années,
la formation des étoiles à cet endroit là.
Et puis le nuage continue son chemin.
Il laisse les étoiles
et les étoiles entre elles,
si elles sont très massives
et bien vont vivre très peu de temps,
si elles sont moins massives
comme le cas du soleil.
Au lieu de vivre 5 millions d'années,
le soleil va lui lui vivre
un peu plus de 10 milliards d'années.
L'autre cas de figure,
c'est si vous avez le nuage de gaz
qui se promène
et il y a une étoile
qui, elle, va exploser.
C'est ça arrive Quand les étoiles meurent,
certaines étoiles explosent
en explosant, ça crée une déflagration
rapide dans le nuage de gaz nébuleuse.
Et donc, à ce moment là, la nébuleuse part
aussi en petits morceaux.
Et vous avez des concentrations de matière
qui vont donner naissance à des étoiles
et à des disques protoplanétaire
qui a encore beaucoup de choses
à découvrir ?
Oui, oui,
parce que moi je vous simplifie énormément
les explications, mais dans la réalité,
ce n'est pas aussi simple.
Mais voilà, en gros, les deux deux
schémas directeurs
pour comprendre un petit peu,
par exemple, ce qui s'est passé chez nous
il y a 5000000000 d'années.
Il y a 5000000000 d'années,
il y avait un grand nuage de gaz,
il y avait le soleil qui est apparu avec
à peu près 1000 autres étoiles.
Et aujourd'hui, on pense qu'il
doit y avoir à peu près trois ou quatre
étoiles.
Sœur du soleil, encore vivante,
toutes les autres sont mortes.
Alors
tu parlais tout à l'heure du fait
qu'on pouvait heureusement d'ailleurs
faire les recherches sur Terre
pour comprendre comment fonctionne
le milieu interstellaire.
Et c'est vrai qu'il y a même des Bretons
qui travaille là dessus.
Ils pourraient le découvrir
dans notre numéro spécial.
On a rencontré notamment Sébastien
Le Picard qui,
à Rennes, à l'université de Rennes,
a des grosses machines.
En fait, il n'est pas le seul à travailler
là dessus, mais dans leur équipe,
ils travaillent pour comprendre.
En fait, la composition chimique
des nuages interstellaires, notamment
en ce qu'ils font bien d'autres choses.
Mais c'est vrai
que le matériel est assez impressionnant,
mais je l'avais vu et et ça ne paraît pas.
Mais en fait, sur le campus de Beaulieu,
il y a de sacrés expériences
et on y pense ? Pas forcément.
Mais il y a aussi des astronomes
ici en Bretagne.
On a rencontré aussi.
Il y a des personnes qui travaillent
sur la naissance et la mort, des étoiles
bien sûr.
Et puis aussi des exoplanètes
parce qu'il y a des exoplanètes pour nous
qui qui peuvent errer
dans le milieu interstellaire, c'est ça.
C'est
un petit peu quand même un autre sujet.
Mais il y en a qui s'y perdent.
Oui, c'est
ce qu'on est en train de découvrir.
Alors pourquoi ?
On pense ?
En tout cas, une chose est sûre, c'est
que toutes les planètes naissent autour
d'une étoile.
Les planètes ne peuvent pas naître
comme cela spontanément
dans le milieu dit interstellaire.
C'est le cas.
Vous voyez un jour monter ma petite pièce
d'un centime.
Les planètes sont vraiment concentrées
au niveau de la pièce.
Et quand on
disait après tout, à l'heure, jusqu'à
une année lumière,
il y a des morceaux de comètes,
ça veut dire en gros jusqu'à dix mètres.
Autour de cette pièce, il y a des éléments
qui appartiennent encore
au système solaire, mais
qui sont dans un volume qui est tel que
on a très peu de chances de les croiser.
Donc ensuite, tout le reste,
tout le reste, oui, c'est vissé
comme on disait du vide.
Et il y a un petit point
on parlait des sondes Voyager.
Par exemple, visuellement,
je voulais que tu nous en parle.
Voilà le suivant, mais c'est très bien.
Est ce que tu peux nous raconter
cette aventure ?
Les sondes, Voyager ?
C'est vrai que parfois on nous dit
Oh là là, elles sont où.
Alors toujours par rapport
à notre pièce de 0,01€,
vous rajoutez en gros
même pas un centimètre
et elles sont à un centimètre
à peu près de la pièce pour retrouver
un beau schéma dans notre numéro,
on a essayé en tout cas deux fois.
C'est la NASA qui a fait.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
de se rendre compte
de ces distances
et de où Elles peuvent être alors
En tout cas, les sondes ont été conçues
dans les années 60 et lancées en 77
il me semble 76 77
et elles sont parties normalement
pour aller voir Jupiter et Saturne.
Donc à l'intérieur notre pièce,
on est en gros pour aller jusqu'à
un millimètre, voire deux millimètres
depuis le centre de la pièce.
Et puis, comme on s'est rendu compte
qu'elle pouvait encore fonctionner,
il y en a une. On l'a éjectée.
Elle sort du système solaire
par en dessous, en quelque sorte.
Mais l'autre, on s'est dit
on va prolonger encore
et on la reprogrammé à distance.
C'était la première fois
que l'homme était capable de reprogrammer
le vol directeur d'une sonde
et on a utilisé l'effet gravitationnel
d'Uranus
puis de Neptune pour prolonger
l'usage de la sonde.
Alors la dernière planète
qu'elle a vu, la sonde Voyager deux,
c'est en 1989
et c'était la planète Neptune.
Et depuis 1989, c'est fini.
Il n'y a plus,
il n'y a plus
d'autres planètes,
donc elles sont sorties.
Elles ont poursuivi leur chemin,
elles ont poursuivi leur chemin
et c'était inattendu. Bruno.
Oui, oui, parce que normalement,
elles auraient dû tomber en panne.
Du moins,
c'est ce qu'on pensait. Très costaud donc.
Mais voilà,
on a utilisé des matériaux intéressants.
Et puis surtout, il faut un générateur
d'énergie parce que les panneaux solaires,
quand vous arrivez sur Mars,
c'est la limite.
On arrive à en faire quelques uns
pour la planète Jupiter.
Mais alors là,
il faut des panneaux solaires,
ça devient des champs en surface quoi.
Donc il faut utiliser autre chose.
Et là, là dessus, les Américains
sont très forts pour les générateurs
au plutonium, ils maîtrisent parfaitement
leur technologie
et le plutonium donc est enfermé dans
un container
qui est associé à la sonde et qui voyage
et qui va générer
du courant électrique
pour au moins 30 ans.
Sauf que vous voyez que l'on est en 2022,
donc les sondes sont parties
il y a presque 50 ans quoi ?
Et ça continue de fonctionner,
mais elles n'avaient pas été prévues.
On pensait pas qu'elles auraient continué
de survivre dans ce milieu
interstellaire, dans ce vide radioactif,
puisqu'il y a des particules de partout.
Et bien, elles continuent de survivre
et l'émetteur qu'elles utilisent est très,
très faible, beaucoup plus faible
que celui qui se trouve
dans nos téléphones portables.
Et on arrive avec des grandes antennes
depuis la Terre à capter le signal
émis par les sondes.
Il met à peu près
15 h actuellement pour nous parvenir
et ces sondes nous
permettent rien
qu'en analysant la trajectoire,
il y a encore des instruments
qui fonctionnent dessus.
Ils peuvent,
on arrive à mesurer la distance
et on arrive aussi à savoir
quelle est la densité de la matière
qu'il y a autour de la sonde.
Et c'est comme ça
qu'on a découvert que le Soleil
avait une limite d'interaction
entre ces flux de particules
et le milieu interstellaire, qu'on
appelle l'héliopause, en quelque sorte.
C'est ça franchi, donc.
Les deux sondes
ont quitté l'héliopause du soleil.
Alors non seulement
il y a les sondes Voyager,
mais il y a les sondes pionnières
qui sont sur le même châssis.
Et donc ça fait quatre sondes
actuellement qui s'éloignent de nous
et qu'on ne pourra plus jamais rattraper.
Et elles apportent donc
beaucoup de données qui ont été finalement
un peu inattendues également.
J'imagine que ça a dû faire un bond aussi
au niveau de la recherche
avec toutes les données
qui ont pu être recueillies
ont eu des surprises
en finalement dans les données récoltées.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que ça
nous permet de voir en trois dimensions
l'environnement du soleil
parce qu'il y a une sonde qui est
par au dessus, l'autre par en dessous
en quelque sorte,
et en faisant le croisement des données
qu'elles nous donnent.
Ça nous donne une idée du cocon dans
lequel est enfermé le système solaire.
C'est à dire que quand je vous montre
une pièce de 0,01€ d'euro,
il y a des couches intermédiaires
supplémentaires
qui sont en interaction
avec le milieu, dit interstellaire.
Donc le milieu interstellaire,
c'est à dire que les autres étoiles,
le Soleil n'étant pas tout seul,
il y a 400000000000 d'étoiles
dans notre propre galaxie, Donc chacune
émet de la lumière, émet des photons
et ça se bagarre entre
les étoiles pour faire en sorte que nous,
on voit les lumières
et donc tout cela bien.
Ça crée des des conflits,
des densités qui varient
et on se rend compte
donc que le soleil a une zone
dans laquelle nous on est
relativement protégé en quelque sorte
du milieu interstellaire,
mais on reçoit quand même des particules,
mais on n'a pas du tout les mêmes effets
quand on sort de ce cocon
autour du soleil.
Donc ça, c'est intéressant
parce qu'une fois qu'on comprend ça,
une fois qu'on a un modèle avec le soleil,
on peut l'utiliser comme référence
et comparer avec d'autres étoiles.
Et en déduire qu'une étoile
qui a telle masse,
qui a telle particularité physique,
eh bien elle doit avoir
aussi un champ gravitationnel
comparable avec les interactions
que nous on connaît au niveau du Soleil.
Et du coup, pour les exoplanètes,
les exoplanètes.
On peut comparer quand on trouve
des planètes qui mettent douze ans
pour faire un tour autour
d'une étoile ou qui mettent
que trois jours ou quelques heures
on en déduire ce que nos sondes
et nos télescopes
mesurent dans le système solaire
pour avoir une meilleure idée.
On n'a pas l'idée juste,
mais on a une idée
quand même qui est proche de la réalité.
Donc c'est par effet de comparaison
qu'on arrive à comprendre les choses
et on mesure Et
les technologies d'aujourd'hui ?
Quand on pense à ce
qu'ils ont envoyé en 77, c'était déjà.
C'est quand même quelque chose
pour que ce soit encore costaud,
donc ça résiste au milieu interstellaire.
C'est vrai
que finalement, les matériaux ont su
bien résister.
Ils ont été conçus pour résister.
L'informatique, c'est l'équivalent
de ce qu'il y avait dans une montre.
L'électronique,
les toutes premières calculettes,
Eh bien, c'est
les sondes.
Actuellement, elles ont ça, c'est à dire ?
Elles ont la technologie
d'il y a 50 ans, 50 ou 60 ans ou.
Et donc la récolte de données.
Elles se passent avec du matériel
qui, elles, se fait que du matériel
qui date de l'époque.
Ou comment on adapte avec l'informatique
d'aujourd'hui.
Il n'y a aucun problème.
C'est à dire que tout est bon pour
en sciences, comme instrument de mesure
pour qu'ils soient vieux
ou qu'ils soient modernes.
Tout est bon pour qu'on
puisse, après faire des croisements
de données, de pensées, de réflexions.
Je vais prendre un autre exemple
Vous avez les stations météo
qui ont été mises à la campagne
il y a déjà maintenant un peu plus
d'un siècle que Météo France existe.
Il faut utiliser toujours les mêmes
outils de manière à
ce que, avec le temps,
on ait une courbe où.
On puisse en tout cas
avoir des relevés qui tiennent la route,
que l'on peut comparer avec ce qu'il
y avait il y 100 ans.
Et dans un premier temps, on a cru
parce que les villes se sont agrandies.
Les stations qui étaient à la campagne
se sont retrouvées dans les villes.
Et quand on met du bitume sur les routes,
ça chauffe.
Donc dans un premier temps, on compensé
le réchauffement
que l'on notait dans les thermomètres.
Avec le fait que bien oui,
la station était à la campagne.
Maintenant dans la ville,
une ville est toujours plus chaude
et c'est
le satellite qui lui va nous montrer qu'il
y a vraiment un réchauffement global.
Et bien on fait la même chose
avec les instruments
astronomiques,
on a des sondes, des télescopes
qui sont aussi bien dans l'espace
que sur Terre.
On a différents types d'instruments
et la possibilité
d'observer dans différents
types de rayonnements.
Et quand on fait un brassage de tout ça,
on arrive à en déduire
des données intéressantes
sur la dynamique de la galaxie,
le mouvement des étoiles.
J'ai rien dit,
mais notre pièce de 0,01€ d'euro
dans notre galaxie, Le Soleil, voyage
à une vitesse d'à peu près 25 kilomètres
par seconde par rapport aux autres étoiles
qui sont autour de lui.
Donc rien, rien n'est figé, tout bouge
exactement comme si on avait
un peloton
des vélos qui tournent sur un vélodrome.
Les vélos par rapport entre eux,
il n'y a pas que le milieu.
Aujourd'hui, l'espace des sciences aussi.
Mais on est désolé, on est en plein
en plein démontage de l'exposition.
Mais c'est bien, on est dans la dynamique.
Voilà. Mais turbulent.
Pour donner une idée.
Donc entre les coureurs cyclistes,
quand ils tournent dans le Vélodrome
et bien entre eux, ils se déplacent à un,
mais pas deux par seconde,
même quelques centimètres par seconde.
Mais quelqu'un qui est, lui est assis
au milieu du vélodrome.
Il va aller voir, tourner, mettons,
50 ou 60 kilomètres heure.
Eh bien, par rapport à ses copains.
Notre pièce 0,01€ d'euro ou le soleil
voyage en gros à 25 kilomètres par seconde
avec les copines autour.
Mais l'ensemble tourne à 250 kilomètres
par seconde autour de la galaxie
et mes 250 millions d'années à peu près
pour faire un tour dans notre galaxie.
Donc tout ça, ça bouge.
Attendez vous de Namco ?
Bonsoir.
Alors moi j'avais une petite question,
il y a quand même pas mal de particules
dans notre galaxie.
Alors Est ce que ce serait possible
qu'il y ait une étoile dans notre galaxie
ou en tout cas d'autres formes de planètes
ou de choses qui se créent ?
En tout cas,
tout est possible.
Voilà, c'est
quand on voit la diversité
qu'il se passe, par exemple sur Terre
ou à partir d'éléments chimiques.
Quand on regarde, on analyse la chimie
d'un individu.
On y trouve tout d'abord de l'hydrogène,
ce qui correspond
à l'élément le plus abondant
qui est dans l'univers de l'hélium.
Il n'y en a pas chez nous
parce que c'est trop volatil.
Mais après, vous pensez un océan,
vous voyez,
la vie est née dans les océans
ou comme oxygène.
C'est comme carbone
et comme azote, C'est un moyen de retenir.
Eh bien, rien que ces quatre éléments,
l'hydrogène,
l'oxygène, le carbone et l'azote.
Ça fait plus de 95% de
la matière qui nous constitue,
nous, êtres humains.
Ça veut dire qu'on
est constitué d'une matière
qui est
dans l'ordre logique
de la matière
que l'on trouve dans l'univers.
On est constitué d'une matière banale.
Donc, à partir de là,
on va pouvoir se dire
que tout est possible dans l'univers.
Mais il y a comme des règles,
des lois qui vont faire en sorte
que certains
agencements de la matière est possible
et d'autres ne l'est pas.
Et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrive à comprendre
qu'il y a des planètes géantes gazeuses
et il y a des planètes solides
comme nous.
On a. La Terre
est une planète solide, rocheuse.
Jupiter est une planète géante
et trouver une planète,
par exemple liquide,
ça c'est pas possible.
Ça ne veut pas dire que ça n'existe pas.
C'est juste que
dans l'état actuel de notre connaissance,
on n'a pas trouvé une planète liquide.
Alors quand on dit liquide, ça peut être,
je pense.
On peut imaginer une planète de mercure
liquide ou je n'en
sais rien, mais on n'a pas trouvé.
Merci beaucoup.
Donc on peut tout imaginer.
Finalement, on peut tout imaginer, mais
oui, ou alors une planète cubique,
ça n'existe pas non plus.
Il y a plein de choses
qu'on peut imaginer.
Puis la réalité nous ramène
et nous dit oui,
mais non, ça c'est pas possible.
Mais en parlant de réalité de possible
ou d'impossible,
j'aimerais bien que tu explique au public
ce que tu m'as expliqué.
Quand on s'est vu
pour le dossier de Sciences Ouest,
on a parlé de voyage interstellaire.
T'es un peu dans la
science fiction ? Peut être.
C'est vraiment
impossible d'aller là bas, mais
aujourd'hui en tournée, aujourd'hui,
oui, on ne peut pas.
Alors ce qui fait
la force de l'être humain, c'est que
quand on dit que ce n'est pas possible
et il fera tout pour pour y arriver,
vous savez,
c'est ça qui fait la différence,
je dirais, entre l'être humain et l'animal
une vache, un lapin,
la vache et les dans son champ,
les tranquilles lapins,
une carotte, il est tranquille.
Et puis il y a une grande montagne
très haute à côté
et ils sont en train de brouter.
Mais l'être humain, lui, va se dire
Mais moi, j'irai bien faire un tour
là où tu penses qu'une vache
n'irait pas dans le milieu interstellaire,
eh bien, on n'a pas trouvé de vache
à faire de l'alpinisme.
Donc elle s'arrête à un certain niveau.
Mais elles ne vont pas plus haut
parce qu'elles se disent là,
c'est n'importe quoi.
Et bien l'être humain, lui, il se dit Moi
j'y vais.
Et pourquoi il va au sommet de l'Everest
alors qu'il n'y a rien à manger ?
Il n'y a rien, il ne fait pas bon vivre
ou on est prêt à mourir.
Mais il y en a qui y vont là.
Maintenant,
on se dit on va aller vers la lune.
La Lune,
c'est trois jours pour y aller,
trois jours pour revenir.
Donc s'il y a un problème,
on est quand même à côté.
Mais il y en a
qui pense déjà aller vers Mars.
Alors Mars, il faut six mois pour y aller.
Et puis quand on est sur Mars, comme Mars,
mais deux fois moins de temps
que la Terre
pour faire un tour autour du soleil,
c'est un peu comme quand vous êtes sur
un circuit de voiture,
vous dépassez une voiture, vous allez
deux fois plus vite qu'elle va vous sauter
la voiture pour aller dans l'autre
au bon moment quand ça se croisent.
Mais quand vous avez sauté,
vous ne pouvez pas sauter aussitôt
puisque votre voiture, comme elle va
deux fois plus vite, est déjà passée.
Donc il faut attendre
qu'elle ait fait un tour
et qu'elle revienne.
Et bien, pour le cas de mars,
vous comptez deux ans
de voyage, ça,
vous mettez six mois pour y aller.
Vous êtes obligé d'attendre
au moins un mois sur Mars.
Donc il n'y a pas de supermarché là bas.
Je ne sais pas comment on fait
et ensuite il faut neuf mois
pour revenir vers la terre
et vous pouvez pas revenir
actuellement vers la Terre
en sautant de Mars à la Terre.
Parce que quand vous avez quitté Mars,
vous allez être attiré
d'abord par le soleil
et donc parce que vous allez être attiré.
Vous allez prendre de la vitesse
et parce que vous allez prendre
de la vitesse, vous allez accélérer.
Alors vous voulez ralentir
pour aller atterrir sur terre.
Autrement, vous vous écrasez.
Eh bien,
le seul moyen qu'on ait aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'un astronaute qui est sur Mars.
S'il quitte Mars
pour revenir vers la Terre, il faut qu'il
fasse une partie du tour du soleil.
Il plonge vers le soleil,
il va le contourner
et passer près de Vénus
et se servir de l'attraction de Vénus
pour ralentir le vaisseau.
Parce qu'on n'a pas de moteurs aujourd'hui
suffisamment puissant
pour ralentir le vaisseau
pour arriver sur Terre.
Donc on est obligé de faire tout
un circuit, de ralentir
vers Vénus pour ensuite se diriger
vers la Terre.
Donc on ralentit.
Mais donc ça, c'est déjà rien que
pour faire un petit voyage,
passer un mois sur Mars,
alors on s'y met
pour aller la lune, c'est quelque chose.
Mars, c'en est une autre.
Oui, aller plus loin
encore que les sondes Voyager.
Alors pour aller plus loin,
par exemple.
Autrefois, je disais
vous voulez passer un week end
sur Neptune,
Il faut douze ans pour y aller
et douze ans pour revenir.
Donc vous passez
en gros un quart de siècle à voyager
pour passer un week end sur une planète.
C'est long en fait de faire le tour
de ta petite pièce de un cm.
Oui, c'est très long.
Mais alors, ce qu'on oublie
dans tous les films de science fiction,
on oublie deux choses c'est l'énergie
qu'il faut
parce que votre vaisseau spatial,
il faut l'alimenter en électricité
et il ne faut pas tirer
trop d'électricité.
Donc il faut envoyer une centrale
nucléaire vu les besoins que nous on a.
Mais pour faire fonctionner
une centrale nucléaire,
on ne sait pas faire dans l'espace.
Donc pour l'instant l'énergie,
il y a un problème.
Et puis surtout la radioactivité.
Le milieu interstellaire,
même interplanétaire, est radioactif
et on a envoyé
une sonde à la surface de Mars
qui s'appelle Curiosity
et qui nous a montré qu'au
bout de six mois,
quand vous avez vécu six mois sur Mars,
vous avez attrapé exactement
les mêmes doses radioactives
que les nettoyeurs de Tchernobyl
qui eux, en quelques jours,
sont morts.
Donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui,
envoyer un homme
dans l'espace vers Mars, nonobstant
les problèmes d'énergie, d'alimentation
et tout ça,
on sait que, au bout de six mois,
quand il va arriver sur Mars,
il sera déjà atteint d'un sacré
cancer généralisé.
Quoi ?
Et on ne sait pas quoi faire.
Il faudrait générer un champ magnétique
puissant
pour repousser les protons
et pour générer
un champ magnétique puissant.
Bien.
Il faut une centrale électrique puissante
et on ne sait pas faire tout ça.
Quoi.
C'est pour ça qu'on envoie que des robots.
Donc maintenant, imaginons encore plus
loin.
Admettons, on arrive même.
Imaginons.
Oui, oui, oui. Super super fusée.
On y va en combien de temps à peu près.
Tu me parlez de ?
Alors je le répète,
je te cite oui, il faudrait 100 000 ans.
Voilà, tempère Bruno Mauguin,
il faut 100 000 ans aujourd'hui
pour envoyer un équipage
avec les technologies actuelles
vers l'étoile
la plus proche, c'est à dire par rapport
à notre petite pièce de 0,01€.
A 43 mètres de là.
Alors, tout à l'heure,
je disais 25 000 ans.
Oui, parce que pour les sondes
qui sont beaucoup plus légères,
il n'y a pas besoin
d'oxygène, de nourriture.
Et tout ça donc,
pour un tas de ferraille en quelque sorte,
on peut mettre de la puissance,
c'est léger et ça va aller vite.
Mais pour envoyer un équipage,
il ne faut pas envoyer à toute puissance.
Au départ, il va mourir.
Donc il faut accélérer doucement.
Mais il faut y aller.
C'est beaucoup plus lourd
parce que il faut plein de choses.
Et puis
cet équipage, il savent qu'il est parti
pour 100 000 ans.
Or, aujourd'hui, une civilisation,
en gros, c'est 2000 ans
qui se souviendra dans 100 000 ans,
à quoi ressemblaient les générations
avant ?
Déjà que nous,
on a des menhirs en Bretagne et
on sait même pas
comment ils sont arrivés là.
Mais ils sont arrivés là.
Vous voyez donc
comment entretenir un équipage
à bord de boites de conserve
pendant autant d'années ?
Où eux quand ils vont voyager,
il n'y aura rien à voir
par les hublots, ils verront des étoiles,
il fera tout nuit,
ils auront le temps de se reproduire
parce qu'il y
aura bien quelques années alors
Et bien c'est très bien votre remarque,
ils auront le temps de se reproduire
et ça c'est un énorme problème.
C'est quand ils se reproduisent.
Il faut avoir prévu les modules auparavant
pour pouvoir accueillir.
Mais oui, c'est vrai que
et en fin de compte,
l'ennemi le plus important dans tout ça
que l'on voyage pendant trois jours
dans l'espace
pour atteindre la lune ou à la rigueur,
des milliers d'années
pour atteindre une étoile, c'est l'ennui.
L'être humain, quand il s'ennuie,
il fait des bêtises.
Tant qu'il est occupé, il sait pourquoi
il est là, il sait ce qu'il a à faire.
Mais quand il s'ennuie,
eh bien, il sait qu'il
ne faut pas toucher à ce bouton
ou qu'il ne faut pas tourner la poignée
qui est là.
Mais il y a un moment, il va le faire,
il est constant.
Il aurait temps de s'ennuyer.
Voilà, il aura le temps de disparaître.
Et c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu un débat à un moment.
La NASA sait combien de personnes
il faut au minimum
pour aller faire un tour vers Mars.
Et c'est des bonnes études sociologiques.
Là oui, oui, oui. Comportement humain.
Est ce qu'on est ici ici
comme cinq hommes ?
Est ce qu'on met cinq femmes ?
Est ce qu'on met un équipage mixte ?
Et si on met un équipage mixte,
ils ne vont pas rester
se regarder dans le blanc de l'oeil
S'ils partent pour.
Et donc il faut prévoir
plein d'autres choses.
Et vous savez, là haut, dans l'espace,
les machines à laver,
ça ne marche pas dans l'eau,
ça fait une boule.
Vous pouvez pas laver du linge, c'est pas
possible, donc le linge, faut le jeter.
Donc il faut ramener.
C'est ce qui se passe
avec la station internationale.
Il faut envoyer tous les mois du linge,
de l'oxygène, de l'eau, de la nourriture,
en plus des expériences qui a fermé.
On est constamment tous les mois
obligés d'amener ça
pour que l'équipage puisse survivre.
Quand on dit que Thomas Pesquet
a vécu six mois,
il a effectivement vécu
six mois dans l'espace.
Mais il y a eu du ravitaillement.
Bon, mais quand vous allez vers Mars,
il n'y a pas de ravitaillement
et il n'y a pas des aires d'autoroute ou
je ne sais pas, On ne sait pas faire quoi.
C'est donc vous partez avec tout ?
Et si vous avez oublié l'ouvre boîte,
il va falloir vous débrouiller
pendant deux ans
pour fabriquer un ouvre boîte
avec tout ce que vous pouvez
qui est à bord.
Est ce que vous allez
envoyer des robots alors sur Mars ?
C'est vrai que c'est quand même
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui.
Même un petit hélicoptère.
Oui, mais est ce que du coup,
effectivement, en 100 000 ans,
on peut imaginer que bon, on imagine
même pas.
C'est vraiment pas possible.
Mais est ce qu'on pourrait envoyer
des robots
qui iraient au delà des sondes
Voyager où elles sont aujourd'hui ?
Ils sont vraiment dans le milieu
interstellaire.
Cela aussi, ça paraît ?
Pour l'instant, oui, mais c'est
le seul moyen qu'on ait actuellement,
c'est à dire que nous,
êtres humains, on a jamais été conçu
pour vivre dans l'espace.
Nous, on ne fait pas vivre sans terre.
On peut tourner le problème
dans tous les sens.
On ne peut pas vivre dans l'espace,
on peut survivre,
mais au moindre problème, on meurt,
on est pas fait pour vivre dans l'espace.
Alors, dans un premier temps,
on est dans l'ère de la robotique.
C'est à dire qu'actuellement effectivement
on envoie des robots à droite à gauche.
L'avantage robot, c'est qu'une fois
qu'il a quitté la terre, on l'étend.
Et puis il part.
Il peut voyager un an, dans trois ans
et on le rallume.
Entre temps,
il n'a pas fait grève, il n'a pas
pris de congé ou quoi que ce soit Lui pas.
Voilà. Ils sont ils pas ées
et c'est le gros avantage du robot.
Donc quand on dit robot,
c'est la sonde orbitale,
la sonde qui va atterrir, peu importe.
Et d'autre part, le milieu interstellaire
et interplanétaire.
Est on radioactif ?
Est vraiment pas fait pour nous.
Nous, on a toutes les chances d'être mort
avant même de revenir.
Donc on a intérêt à envoyer
plutôt du matériel.
En plus, on peut l'accélérer.
On a des moteurs ioniques actuellement
qui sont en cours d'utilisation
par les Indiens mais conteste aussi
et qui pour des longs voyages pourrait
effectivement
atteindre des vitesses incroyables.
Donc ça permettrait de réduire le temps
qu'il faut pour pouvoir aller
vers des planètes,
peut être pas, mais vers des étoiles.
Mais n'empêche que ça va se compter encore
avec une échelle de temps
qui nous dépasse complètement.
Donc on peut imaginer par contre
que nous, êtres humains doués de raison,
on se dise bon, on n'est pas fait
pour vivre dans l'espace,
mais on peut créer l'homo espace.
C'est à dire qu'avec la génétique,
avec tout ce qu'on connaît,
on peut peut être créer demain
un être qui est capable d'hiberner,
qui n'est pas capable de s'ennuyer,
qui est capable de à la rigueur
de ne pas s'émouvoir
devant quoi que ce soit de dehors.
C'est moche.
J'ai envie de faire demi tour, non ?
Il y va
et il va obéir bêtement aux ordres.
Et peut être que ce l'homo espace
va coloniser
peut être plus facilement
le système planétaire.
Dans un premier.
Et pourquoi pas mettre au point
des appareils pour aller plus loin ?
Et alors ?
Ce qui est surprenant.
Enfin je pense, je parle beaucoup, mais
ce qui est surprenant, c'est que quand
on ne peut jamais revenir en arrière,
un être humain qui vit sur terre,
il vit, il naît, il vit, il meurt. Bon,
maintenant, si les êtres humains
demain font une colonie sur la lune
et s'ils ont des enfants
parce qu'ils s'ennuient entre béton
et même c'est naturel,
ils vont avoir des enfants.
Les enfants vont être habitués
à vivre avec une gravité
six fois moindre que sur terre.
Donc ces enfants là, si jamais
ils veulent venir sur terre, voir
à quoi ressemblera la planète
de leurs parents, c'est impossible.
C'est comme si vous,
il fallait porter six fois votre poids.
Vous ne pouvez pas porter six fois
votre poids,
votre squelette,
Les muscles, ce n'est pas fait pour.
Donc ça veut dire que tous les enfants
qui vont être sur la Lune
sont les rapatrie pas tout de suite
sur terre, c'est de l'être là.
Sont condamnés à vivre sur la lune,
ils ne peuvent pas faire autre chose.
Et Mars,
mais la gravité est deux fois moindre que
à peu près que sur Terre,
on va se retrouver avec le même problème.
Donc en fin de compte,
on se rend compte que si jamais
on met au point l'homo espace,
ben il pourra vivre sur la lune
et la colonie va rester vivre sur la lune.
Une partie ira sur Mars, il restera vivre
sur Mars et ainsi de suite.
Imaginez qu'un jour
il y a un virus sur terre
planétaire.
Ben je pense que je serai
l'unique martien.
Je dirais non.
Je reviens pas vers la terre,
je reste sur ma planète
et ainsi la vie va se répandre
dans l'univers, dans l'infiniment grand.
On peut imaginer ce scénario
qui pourrait peut être se faire
sur des milliers d'années.
J'en sais rien,
mais en tout cas nous, dans l'état
actuel de la connaissance,
l'état actuel de notre technologie,
on ne peut
pas voyager dans l'espace
comme nous le montre le cinéma.
Bon, alors
on va garder les pieds sur terre alors ?
Et bien c'est ça.
C'est que le fait
d'avoir la tête dans les étoiles,
plus on apprend, plus on se pose
les questions de réponses.
Mais au moins on en a une.
C'est qu'il
faut préserver ce qu'on a sous nos pieds.
Tout à fait.
Bien merci Bruno.
Merci pour tous ces mots, ce voyage.
J'espère que vous avez bien voyagé.
Vous avez pris plein de choses.
N'hésitez Vraiment pas.
Si vous voulez aller plus loin
et à découvrir ce que je disais.
Les recherches en tout cas sur ce sujet,
les recherches
des scientifiques en Bretagne, est
ce que c'est vraiment la science Ouest ?
C'est ça, c'est l'actualité
de scientifiques dans la région,
donc n'hésitez pas à le découvrir.
Et puis, en tout cas,
on se retrouve aussi le mois prochain,
Alors cette fois ci
on parlera du microbiote.
Alors là, c'est
un autre sujet aussi, un autre univers.
Oui, il y a une question, une question.
Attendez, mon collègue va venir vous voir
et c'était vraiment la dernière seconde.
Allez y, on vous écoute.
Pardon, je m'excuse. Pas de souci.
Vous parliez justement de sondes
qui seront envoyées.
Mais moi,
je me pose la question des débris
parce que finalement
les sondes ont une durée de vie limitée
et on produit quand même
pas mal de déchets sur terre
et on est en train d'en produire également
dans l'espace interstellaire.
Est ce que les astronomes,
les scientifiques réfléchissent à ça ?
Ou alors c'est vraiment une idée qui ?
Ben oui,
ils prennent pas du tout en compte
le fait qu'ils polluent également
l'univers,
serait tenté de dire l'être intelligent.
On repère son intelligence par les ordures
qui sèment à droite et à gauche.
On en voit très très intelligents
et je crois que oui oui Alors
effectivement c'est un problème maintenant
parce que
autour de la terre,
on a beaucoup de déchets
auxquels on
n'avait pas pensé un instant à l'époque.
Quand on a envoyé le premier satellite,
qu'aujourd'hui il y en ait des milliers
et surtout qui sont indispensables
pour notre vie.
C'est ça le truc, c'est
qu'on a des satellites
pour la météo,
pour les télécommunications,
pour que suivre l'évolution de la terre.
Et ça nous est tout à fait indispensable.
C'est du matériel.
Alors tout ce qu'on envoie autour
de la terre,
tôt ou tard, finira par retomber terre.
Parce que dans le vide interplanétaire
et interstellaire, ce n'est pas le vide
parfait.
Et donc les particules finissent.
Quand on a un objet qui avance
dans les particules,
c'est comme une voiture
qui traverse un nuage de moustique.
Vous avez le pare brise
qui est recouvert de moustiques.
Eh bien, c'est pas un micro impact.
On peut les mesurer et constater
que ça fait ralentir la voiture,
mais de quasiment rien.
Le moustique ne peut pas arrêter un TGV,
bien sûr, mais dans l'espace, à force
d'entrer en collision avec les particules,
eh bien, ça ralentit les satellites.
Et donc tout ce qu'on envoie autour de
la Terre finira par retomber sur Terre.
Certains satellites mettent
quelques années seulement et d'autres
vont mettre des milliers d'années
pour retomber sur terre.
Et quand ils retombent sur terre,
ils sont fabriqués de telle manière
qu'ils se désintègrent.
En gros 99%.
Donc il reste quasiment plus rien.
On a à peu près trois satellites par jour
à nous retomber dans l'atmosphère.
C'est sous forme de poussière,
donc on sans rien.
Par contre pour les autres,
ça dure sur la lune, sur Mars,
mais ils sont là
pour des millions d'années.
Donc un jour,
il y aura peut être des éboueurs
qui vont ramasser tout ça
pour remettre tout en état.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est incomparable
avec la pollution qu'on a sur terre
qui également devant.
C'est un autre sujet mais qui pourrait
être maîtrisé, contrôlé et qui n'a pas
d'objet scientifique qui n'a pas d'intérêt
scientifique pour l'instant.
Nous, on sait, c'est un sujet en soi
et c'est un débat
qui est très très intéressant.
Ça nous donne des idées de sujets.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet qui est étudié bien sûr
par et pour les sondes planétaires.
Par exemple, on parlait des sondes
Voyager, alors là, elles sont là,
on ne peut pas aller les chercher.
Elles vont tellement vite
qu'il faudrait pouvoir aller plus vite
pour aller les récupérer.
Et puis il faut pouvoir ralentir,
donc il faut transporter de l'énergie.
C'est très compliqué
actuellement, ça part et l'idéal,
c'est que ça tombe dans une étoile
parce qu'une étoile, c'est
une énorme centrale nucléaire
qui va recombiner,
désintégrer les matériaux
et les redistribuer dans l'univers
dans le milieu interstellaire.
Donc l'idéal, c'est que toutes les ordures
qu'on fabrique,
c'est de la poussière d'étoiles.
Eh bien,
c'est de les replonger dans les étoiles
pour repartir sous forme de poussière.
Et un jour,
il y aura peut être quelqu'un d'autre.
On va faire la même chose que nous.
J'arrive
à nous faire rêver avec des déchets.
Il me passionne.
Mais en tout cas, merci encore.
Bonne soirée à toutes
et à tous et à très bientôt. Merci.
Puis.